y la pandemia no tiene fin en américa
latina' al contrario vuelve a empeorar
con gran velocidad la región ya acumula
más de un millón de muertes
aproximadamente el tercio de las
víctimas mortales en todo el mundo y
tiene una de las tasas de mortalidad más
alta mientras que el promedio mundial es
de 46 muertes por cada 100.000
habitantes en américa latina' los
fallecimientos suben a 162 además según
un reciente informe de la cruz roja seis
países de la región están en riesgo de
colapso sanitario especialmente
uruguay-argentina donde tanto las
muertes como los contagios se encuentran
en sus picos más altos en tensión a
pesar de las persistentes altas tasas de
contagio mucha gente y lugares ya no
mantienen las medidas de salud pública
que sabemos que funcionan contra el kobe
19 quizás todavía no sabemos el impacto
completo de esta pandemia
es tan verde
solo entre el 17 y el 23 de mayo los
países latinoamericanos registraron más
de 12 millones de nuevos casos de kobe
19 y 31 mil muertes una cifra que lleva
estable desde hace algunas semanas en
niveles alarmantes además la vacunación
avanza con lentitud en la mayoría de
países toda sudamérica lleva 114 3
millones de dosis de fármacos inoculadas
aproximadamente la mitad de las
administradas por solo eeuu sin embargo
las buenas noticias son que este viernes
concluyó la última fase de los ensayos
clínicos de la vacuna cubana soberana y
que brasil reinicio la fabricación local
del fármaco de astrazéneca